you and welcome to punch-drunk
sportswear winners win
it's another Tuesday back in the saddle
with everybody fight nanny getting later
and later
just text me I'll be there in ten
minutes ten minutes oh my what time is
it 11:00 that's unprofessional
she makes tens of dollars on the show
you should show up a little more respect
tens of dollars lives to it she's got to
get rid of that baby that baby just
really ruined her style well I mean
when's she so much cooler when she
didn't have a baby I mean she was only
one minute late then Yeah right
it's that baby why does she bring the
baby the baby and the doll can hang out
together like they're animals both of
them hey Chad where you gonna be uh [ __ ]
we're doing a show at the rec room yes
on the 23rd of March 23rd you jim
Florentine chill Bartnik and myself
yeah and possibly bill burr what I'm
trying to sell tickets you got Triple E
so happy so and then on the 21st we're
at the dojo we're doing another show
Jason would you like to do that show yes
love to you're booked
holy Jim Jason Tebow sold out sold out
so we got a builder we got Joe DeRosa
maybe chad will do it joe bartnick
myself jim Florentine so we got to get
some [ __ ] snatch in there or else
everybody will start crying
who's a good snatch to put it in there
who's that hot chick I was on you about
that was on that one show the blonde
Kate Quigley know Kate's cute but not
what's her name
[ __ ] I forgot her name I told you she's
cute they're all cute oh look she's all
Carli Forrester oh yeah Carlisle Forster
baby
yeah I'm not again said she just did my
last show I like to mix it in I gotta we
gotta mix it up yeah you think Rappaport
would come back yeah text him he's gonna
do this show maybe he should come on
dude he's supposed to be next Tuesday
I don't want to see he's a fake gasps
hide him ride I'll text him right now
chasing Tebow where you gonna be
maybe the Comedy Store this week and
I'll be at the dojo on what's that date
again the 21st buckle your seat belts
kids that's where I'll be
it's about to get crazy I'm doing both
those shows when does this come out
Johnny when you put this out today so
tonight is uh I was so annoyed with you
he's like today
yeah Johnny gets annoying Johnny is
annoying he hates you Johnny is like if
the Seattle Airport was a person okay I
know I'm sorry now he's really annoyed
what happened Johnny what happened
Oh Johnny coming in hot why didn't you
tell me where to go move the car I'm
gonna go move it um I'm gonna be there
this weekend I am in New Jersey Morris
Plains I'm at Tiff's comedy club first
show sold out thank you second show is
at 10:30 it's a Saturday 10:30 show come
get weird myself and XG we have the rec
room I am doing the we're doing the
tinfoil hat waking Arizona tour that is
March 28th at the house of comedy myself
Eddie Bravo X G and then the 29th we are
in Tucson and we are at the one nine one
tool Club come down those cool club
that's appropriate hello hit the bricks
kid hits the bricks so make it a minute
it's a minute one yeah what else so go
all my face and then hey NorCal I'm
coming I'm going to be in Sunnyvale I'm
going to be at the rooster T feathers
April 4th through the 7th so come get
weird all right that's that's that's the
business right there got all the way so
much to talk about so excited I
we wanna talk off for the final time a
little bit about Brody's memorial last
night yeah it was great it was wonderful
because they did a great job was great
they did a great job
lotta lot of tears last night Oh crying
the whole time
me too a lot of [ __ ] too I'm trying to
lighten up the moment let him in let him
back
yeah talk about my talk about his friend
it is a lot of hot [ __ ] there last night
what Brody died right it was fun dude it
was it was weird because you know the
Comedy Store had a hard job impossible
I'm apologizing have to get the family
in letting the family know how much he's
loved by having some faint somewhat
famous people go obviously Zac Kelvin
Angus the cast of The Hangover was there
yeah I mean Bradley Cooper Ed Helms was
that same dude yeah I mean come on
that's that's [ __ ] he was John I am
and he's Jon Hamm the actor yeah the guy
with the big that it is that it
yeah he's Cardinals fan here's the
Cardoza like the Cardinals [ __ ] the
Cardinals so yeah it was kind of crazy
the video montages were great you just
realized how funny Brody was of course
you know what it is man this town is
just it's they're lazy thinkers and they
didn't know how to use them Steve
Randolph murdered last night he did
great he did great what do you go first
show second show first row yeah he was
great and so is a second show Rick
Ingraham made me laugh it was he was
very appropriate it great well yeah
Ingram did was what Brian Brian Holtzman
normally did and ultimately crepe
Holtzman did okay he got a little weird
towards him but usually he slays like
the best time see Holtzman is in a
memorial of course but you know after
after you know a couple people gone up
and get busted Brody's balls I don't
know he just got weird but it was a
frosted good
Ross was great was what baseball players
were there they said there were baseball
players there yeah there's a bunch
probably the Bad News Bears
oh really yeah I love Jeff Jeff Ross
went up like right around the middle and
the first thing that he said was he was
the first one to really take the piss
out of him or what everybody goes um
after hearing all these stories and he
went on like after the family and
whatnot and he goes after hearing all
these stories about Brody I can see why
he killed himself
god bless tape Fletcher - I stood next
to him the whole time and man I mean you
know the stand next to a guy like that
that's so sensitive and also could kill
anybody with his bare hands and for me
in him to dick be arm in arm and just
crying the whole time and it just you
know - you know everybody takes it [ __ ]
rotating a lot of people in [ __ ]
metate about the time he was on the show
you have to understand those two were
great friends
yeah and they were friends two days
later yeah
and we're friends for a year that was
three years ago
listen everybody you know I mean like
everybody gets in a fight with me at one
point and at some point you got in a
fight with Brody it was just oh yeah how
it was back in the day lately
later on it was you know did that what
people don't know and in Tate and I
always joke about this is that after
that fight and you guys are both gone
and I had Tate and I had Brody on him
like this can't go wrong yeah
- my two of my great friends and they've
always been on the show and Brody came
in in a thing came in hot you know just
he was just in a mood in a mood oh it's
that video that's on punch-drunk yeah in
a mood and then they they get into it
and Tate storms or Brody storms off and
me and Tate were like whoa that was
weird and then like three hours later
Brody calls me or sends me a text that
says I feel like that was good hahaha
like you stormed off like you know I do
drama people like it people like it like
it but he says they like it when I
scream at everybody then you didn't
welcome to punch yeah yeah so I mean it
was fun to watch that
that's an impossible task to get every
store the store did such a good job
family members just kept go I'm II like
in true like you know that that show
reminded me of like 2002 ft Comedy Store
where there's no loss and everybody just
ran to life I just ran to life yeah well
I mean the first part of that they're
not comics didn't know what the light
was they didn't know what to look for
that or you know that's probably the
first time you know you talked into a
microphone yeah you know blue you know
but that was Brody yeah but what does
that do those first 12 people this was a
memorial service you know a funeral I
wanted to the next 900 people have a set
list yeah I wanted Dan to play them off
like [ __ ] Oscars so they eventually
did yeah okay let's go who'd he do that
to a couple times no stuff they made it
do that what yeah it was a long show
that's a long time yeah my home
eventually the family left they're like
we got enough of this yeah we get we're
gonna enjoy rody Stevens impression I
love how all the food was yeah what was
the significance behind that it was
Brody's it was those are the things
Brody loved it was subway and whoppers
with no cheese loved the Starbucks
oh yeah the COO yeah good so good dude
shoutout to the Comedy Store you imagine
how much money they lost yesterday for
closing that down and giving out free
booze and food I mean yeah just from a
business standpoint how much money they
lost to honor someone so that was a
really class act by the whole community
yeah they just got tipped you know the
store just got tip last night you know
it's just like that Brody spot at the
end which used to be the same Tripoli
spot but you know I'm over that I know
how you can get it back available oh you
play drums on a chair but I mean like
that's a weird spot because it is it is
a weird spot night it is a privilege to
do that spot cuz you can go longer you
can do an hour
you want and if the show if the show is
shorter you can have a full room and do
an hour in la great in that room but
it's also sad because it's like weird
because it's usually empty so when you
get an earlier spot it can [ __ ] with
your head yeah when you should be you
know just go up there and do your thing
it was but that's the Perla G to that
spot man yeah I did it for about 12
years when you know hmm all at all good
night good night did you see Brody's
first set they selling record his first
sat in the Oh are they put that I saw a
little bit of the video yeah yeah yeah
yeah you see how they introduced them
Stephen Brody Steve Brody just really
his real name their cremating him is
that the word on street is I don't know
yeah I didn't get a lot of information
on what exactly they're doing I I don't
I don't kind of wanted I don't want to
know and I don't wanna know I would like
to know if he's gonna be buried
somewhere I didn't go see him yeah they
don't drop his ashes on Arizona State's
baseball field let's do that rodeo or
Wrigley where do you think you'd want
the most Wrigley did you like the job
pitching for the Cubs more you like the
Cubs more I think you want his ashes on
that Starbucks in the valley I think we
should uh we should spread them all over
pornhub like go to the high corner since
because he loved porn so much yeah I
just throw it yeah yeah yeah yeah I
think you should spread the ashes on
Bette DSi bet the aside for all your bet
needs go to bet DSi use a promo code
punch 25 and you will get what did they
say $25 yeah that's how that works
punch 25 equals $25 plus you will
whatever donut whatever you deposit they
will match it up to $500 and guess
what's coming guys March Madness I let
her time to bed love are we doing
brackets yeah we always do it does March
Madness yeah we do brackets donk
we bracket away dude what do we win is
there a prize yeah just yeah you get to
say hey you won the greatest [ __ ]
sports car
many podcasts brackets dude that's your
price and that you know there's a kid at
brackets no mad [ __ ] at Brody's [ __ ]
memorial yeah
comic memorials is the best it's the
only place people walk around going hey
anyone got coke we did we did our
friends [ __ ] Memorial down pat dojo
yeah
Lindsay Jennings went around just asking
every bite they had cocaine yeah I
bought coke up Bradley Cooper last night
it seemed pretty tame yeah as far as I
done Kim was crying you don't see
dunking me I walked there with him dr.
ken I went there to go dr. Kim was
crying everybody was crying man he's
gone Brody's gone everybody was crying
it was terrible and baseball is just
starting Brody should have hung out by
the way update Cardinals are down three
nothing against bottom of the fifth keep
that going you two get along over there
and you're both baseball's windows
opening day I think 16 days
I can't believe baseball's about to
start a little over two weeks I'm
excited March 28th playing that bad man
Dodgers aren't playing it back by the
way I got our Jersey for guess how much
authentic for which team Dodgers very
weak Jersey for the Dodgers yeah
did you get a Ron Harper Laker Jersey
Tim I would own one of those that'd be
awesome
yeah what about our you know who I
always wanted Dennis Rodman Dennis
Rodman Lakers when he was on the team
for 10 games I forgot about that 90 yeah
where's my Jersey you got me I'm gonna
give it to you what are you doing with
it you'll get it
at some point I'll bring it tonight to
the College Jersey is it you got me I'll
look who's up Lucas here but you're
getting you he got me a clipper Jersey
which Clippers you'll see oh oh you
don't even know what clipper know if you
got a surprise Jersey coming is it a
current or an old we blaming all your
problems in your life on your baby
because I was and then I'll blame Brody
no but I like I wish I was there and
then
just didn't get home till like 3:00 and
then I wanted to talk about it also then
max gets up at like 6:00 so I kind of
didn't sleep the whole night so I'd a
meltdown I'm not going to punch I
haven't slept I'm so mean I think it's
so progressive of you to have a trans
baby I think that's so great
they're called unisex names they're in
right now no max is not a unisex
no yes the girl is two Broke Girls is
new max Jessica Simpson's real she's not
real Mark Zuckerberg daughters named max
this is three girl max I can keep going
that show better things has a daughter
named max on it well you know
retardation so straight I love your
trans baby by the way I love your
transfer are you gonna get your when did
you get her first softball mitt so she
can start getting ready to play teams
with the other leg that's so great so
great she's gonna be the LA Sparks point
guard hey I got an announcement it looks
like I'm gonna be doing pro wrestling at
the next Alice mania I'm trying I'm just
knocking up everybody trying who you Pro
Wrestling jason Ellis it's me and the
team like you guys gonna write out the
script and do all that guess so mighty
choreographic my characters Armageddon
right and I come up Armenian I already
have my whole thing I'm gonna do my
perfume you know I'm a wear wife beater
yeah I'll probably walk out with a trans
chick because our Mo's are no you need
her daughter yeah I'm super excited I
just work with Dawg Thursday what Dolph
Ziggler I was at the house of comedy
he's a cool guy name dropper get him on
the show it was fun Sarah Tiana was
there she's great she's smart she was
there I didn't see her yeah she was
there yeah can I be in it too and here's
my character right I'm gonna go as
Michael Jackson but I'm gonna walk in
with babies hello so you need my baby
too
yeah and if you have a baby baby Fred
I'll take them yeah Aaron from The
Comedy Store whose daughters named
Charlie because that's in right now out
of control your baby's finally paid off
yeah that's perfect
Brett can I read them out trans babies
are perfect for Michael Jackson do you
know a female Larry baby
Lenny that's a girl it's all my parents
hate their children it's cute it's in we
don't hate them you think I would like
be like I hate that name I want to call
her I think George Foreman's daughter
just died didn't she like and she was
like her name is George
georgina or some [ __ ] like she hung
herself two guys did you really yeah the
first article said no foul play the
second one said it was death by hanging
oh my god this is getting out of control
you know she should kill herself in the
George Foreman grill terrible marketing
sounds like horrible tweets when people
don't awful right only 42 and has three
grandkids
hey dude black don't crack I'll be the
first to say it when did she start
having kids like bradlee means yeah yeah
probably nature
I mean she's 42 which means she probably
had a kid who knows but in LA like
people have kids at 42 so that's crazy
yeah grandma yeah yeah yeah I mean dude
it's nuts who'd I mean I met her I met
that this chick who ran a radio show
that I did in Minnesota
um the Tom Bernard the woman who ran the
board yeah yeah she's a grandma
oh really yeah girl yeah I'm like you're
the hottest grandma out there you can
make so much money webcaming yeah that's
my that was my career advice to her
webcam webcam I met oh by the way I met
your two friends you remember the one
girl that we talked about on the show
yeah I did Sarge yeah yeah yeah I did
their podcast they come to your show
they did they were playing around the
nice boobs they came to my show he said
anything I'll say hi they were so nice
and he didn't want to bother me and I
felt so awful that I literally went a
snowstorm to go do their podcast I
didn't recognize her because in her pet
her shirt is tiny tiny boobs yeah she
has monster jugs the story that's why I
knew I was like yeah
monster tits huh yeah yeah but she's a
mom I remember that yeah well mom is
like big no way you were like respect
her she's a mom and he started going
like crazy he sent me a video just her
tits yeah yeah I meant to say yeah you
actually I real too many tagged me and
it happened to happen
I wasn't hating on it yeah it was not
hating on it how was being in the mall
for a week I was I was Jack Nicholson in
the shining I wanted to kill everybody
yeah it was so cold out you couldn't go
anywhere there's no fresh air I had to
stay in the mall yeah
just yesterday it was it still polar
vortex it was cold the last day we
started to warm up a little bit but yeah
man what a long week good to be home
yeah I don't know it's like aren't you
happy you live in a warm place now yes I
respect it
now you're gay now you know why
everybody comes here yeah it's because
you had the traffic sucks but Lee sure
stuck in traffic with incredibly
good-looking people
hooah and the weather's great yeah now I
know why you Bron James came here dude
you think we have homeless people
problems I was just in Spokane
Washington it is scary
damn I mean everywhere everywhere at
least our homeless people are a little
bit more [ __ ] I'll say we I've seen
some good-looking homeless people out
here I've seen some pretty scary ones
too there are some scary ones but the
dude everyone in [ __ ] Spokane the
other their mouths all look like like
haunted fence like just teeth go in
eighteen different directions and it was
just really why are we looking at the
homeless people's mouths because they're
like oh do love teeth you know I love
teeth dawg I love teeth what does that
make me weird but what's happening right
now what do you want to talk about no
I'm just totally listening no you return
mental homeless people yeah
this is a homeless podcast market but
they can't watch it or listen all have
like everything
dollar and he was under sheets I
realized he's like watching like Netflix
they always have fun iPad there's a guy
I live in Los Feliz he sits outside the
bank with his laptop because he gets
free Wi-Fi from the bank yeah he has his
whole life next one [ __ ] Vespas and
[ __ ] you know they're intense have Wi-Fi
I mean it's not that bad they're just
camping out door said oh that's all
they're not homeless
they're just camping yeah it's really
all they're doing shouldn't they really
free rent
whoever there's a lack of plumbing
that's all they need is plumbing yeah
yeah it's crazy how often they do that
well yeah I mean the guys I don't yeah
yeah yeah I love a homeless guy who
doesn't give a [ __ ] I'll [ __ ] on the
sidewalk yeah I mean if I was home it
would eventually we'll hit a point where
like this is how I would [ __ ] you know
when I would [ __ ] I would [ __ ] while I'm
taking forever the cross the street
that's what I would do I would go slow
high unstrung sports the number one
homeless podcast in the world hey Steven
oh no rude rude no I know my nail
clipper and I warned them like a bunch
of time I want that please welcome to
the show again
Ari Shaffir ari how are you oh you're
out you're camping right now no I do a
spring training game hahaha where do you
plan on [ __ ] while you're camping
yeah
I'm not gonna be I didn't get out of my
car - hi Ken and I said like panther
attacks are rare but they do happen we
strongly advise you not to hike alone do
people go missing in the forest all the
time watch yourself Panther attacks yeah
dude Jesus yeah Panthers yeah but we're
in Florida don't get Oh jackal Jaguars
who you with right now I'm gonna make
Morris take a second
the singer or Paul's like three hours
yeah the gay singers the Caleb's you
know hero singer oh I love that [ __ ]
among vegans and Latinos yeah and Adam
II you know thanks I appreciate it yeah
if you like wearing just denim all the
time
you'll love Morrissey that's what I've
learned no thanks I appreciate a real
quick before you get to Jason webby that
I think it's wrong the Amber's not
looking up woman's the compost or I
think I've seen it lineups they're awful
they're almost never oh yeah do going
back for the feel that experience that
experiment crashed hard hard oh yeah
having no receivers for Dec know having
him talking that's that crashed him do
my night football it's like we're doing
good by the way do you guys see that the
Dodgers got really young kid that they
had replaced Vin Scully after one year
he's already gone that guy tried to
follow King on yeah who was that - yeah
I got Barry who was it oh um the British
guy - scumbag what's his name like what
Pierce Morgan who uh who ran a news
broker that hacked into a dead girl's
phone and saw racing emails so that the
family would keep leaving emails and
they could listen to the emails like
what a scumbag am i right Ari am i right
what Ari straight fast don't worry are
you gonna but are you gonna book
punch-drunk again I gonna book it for a
long time hopefully I'll never have to
be there again so Jose you're not gonna
oh are you gonna book punch drunk on
skank Fest this year severe fast oh yeah
yes this is year of their events I love
it dude I love that it's gonna be me
getting back at a lowest over with the
only caveat is I
you piss or [ __ ] that just come on that
guy I'm gonna add to that vomit but what
about re what about it use those what
about calm what about home can you use
come what a great question Jason Tebow
can you use calm okay I ruff stay calm
not allowable but these are all not
allowed was just a booklet bizarre if
it's outside what some bizarre or
anything like that then no smart but
those are the rules alibi no bodily
fluids inside Brooklyn bizarre for
capers hey oh my god I just I just got
word what punch trunk is books getting
questions come on we're gonna go there
again re can we use come or blood or
[ __ ] are pissed that should be the name
of our again hey Ari um last night's
memorial about Brody was pretty great
the family just ramble on it ran the
light I mean just kept going I'm like
you should ban on for six months for
going so long right let me fight the off
stage hey you're not allowed back for
six months I feel like they shouldn't
have even been invited them do their own
[ __ ] memorial this is for us right
right guys yeah we're good dog good dog
yeah I think they killed the dog and
stuffed it you know for the people who
were like you know I want to honor Brody
in his memory you know a lot of you were
saying you know reach out if you're
feeling depressed one by the way just to
anybody else not gonna reach out that's
never gonna happen
thank you thank you thank you you reach
out you gotta reach them but - hey what
can I do to honor his memory
Brody hated liberals everybody was made
very clear last night memory you will go
to get Democrats election just against
that I think he was a few
love bro don't leave otro but he was
very against anti-liberal so you want
honors memory take this next election
you go to get Democrats Brody enjoy it
yeah good point Ari you're just here I'm
point but I could I couldn't agree more
I love everybody honoring him on Twitter
that had blocked him yeah I like and
everybody these stories Oh Brody or
treasurer why'd you block them dude
why'd you block them so are the
treasures dead so what do you think
about punch Trump getting crashing
cancel well we went Jimmy Schubert
myself
Jason and I wasn't here on that one you
okay oh but I'm glad I got kids harder
how many views on that right now
five yeah we went hard and then next
thing you know cancelled got cancelled
like two weeks later the video went
viral with like maybe 15 50 million
views and then the Shogun's law
yeah million it was the episode well Oh
60,000 I mean that does suck that really
saw but but it's crazy that we have that
power now that was talking about the
power we yield now oh yeah dude oh yeah
people are coming up with me last night
thanking me for that [ __ ] tweet did
you and Judd talk last night I heard
chopping block who do we want to go
ahead what a show do you want to go
pissed us off
let's go after Trump yeah yeah
what would you say let's propose object
what would you take there's a way in
Judaism so the D book if you get to
Seoul the dead and you can make it live
again it's sort of experimental things
the Kabbalah but if you're making limit
again in a newborn baby so what do you
say about putting Brody into your pocket
and bloody dude I mean that's the best
of both worlds we get Brody back and you
get to keep your baby I don't
necessarily want
for though that way I'm hungry get your
tits out oh my god she knows how to get
my Toto no she knows baby sorry me doing
people yeah yeah and she like gets them
out in public she knows how to unsound
my bra and everything you just must
watch her dad just [ __ ] work you huh
it's how my dad does it I'll do it -
give me those - yeah because he does
that in front of her all the time
bad news mom I just [ __ ] my pants again
she can talk to all this all just Brody
yeah
it's like one of those teddy bears you
can put like a voice recorder in but is
every time you squeeze it your baby says
them the birdie would say Ari what are
you doing in Florida I'm doing Miami and
I'm going to be paid more is renown
getting killed by hands I do kids it's
great it's gonna be great
there's supposed to be video out there
absorptive right behind home plate like
no money
it's [ __ ] warm I need to get out of
New York nice do you see yourself ever
leave in New York but I did see a world
where I would take the winter and I flew
somewhere else but probably not LA I
don't see an Diego dude if I cash I'd
live oh yeah absolutely that's where you
want live there's video out there Paul
Morrissey out playing Bob Bob Sarah from
first day I got to find that video did
we lose them no that's crazy
then Paul Morrissey the fat [ __ ] red
oh I'm going to watch spring training
game we've played with bottom Sora and
Adam egit refuse to get women's box oh
dammit Horry [ __ ] doing this to me
I don't run over what kind of no of
course I'm not done I abandoned on
[ __ ] air are you do you think the
best way for comedy to be is just 50/50
half women half men even though there's
not as many female cop
damn because I very transclusion okay it
should be a half women half man and or
4545 10% freak other freak out how are
you calling you dork
the screen will get them all together
yeah we'll put them at 10% that will be
at the end of the line up however yeah
also we need to break it down by race
yeah why Latino Inuit they all have a
place at the Comedy Store
what walk funny jokes get to the [ __ ]
laugh facts because we're interested the
Comedy Store were all about diversity
one more day Ari
yeah I hate when the commies show
responds to all that trolling [ __ ]
brenton stop response stop responding
it's just like these people who weren't
gonna come to your club anyways crying
about what's going on your club kisstixx
to kiss to keep coming here but i did
not like this and this I call you're a
customer here you yeah bye-bye do drinks
and we'll hear you've been do you ever
think that maybe the stores packed
because they don't do diversity you
should go to Aborigine night Aborigine
nights coming is most of them did this
make clicking noises and throw
boomerangs but it's gonna be hilarious
what's that tell us woman I heard the
tallest one airs by don't why yeah I
hate when they write their set on their
loincloth and they got a little pygmy
dick
it's [ __ ] uncomfortable yeah hey Ari
are you bringing all your kid I mean you
bring your girlfriend out to Florida
with you know oh nice nice
you are kind friend Ari all right you
find a new place yet find that your last
seconds I had it with me this day also
you need three months run up front I
walk you need this
god is so hard in New York huh three
months rent up front no [ __ ]
there's a guy on Twitter since the Faygo
warrior says Sam needs to fight ari Ari
did I whooped his ass it's gang fest
we've all moved on Ari and I talked
about it you guys were so out of breath
oh yeah I was sick dude the rest of the
podcast yeah I know in my hotel room for
24 hours I couldn't you leave it and I
went I saw how were walking that morning
I did not power wall I did see you buy
an ATM though I did see red band power
walking for you that's just when you had
to take a [ __ ]
that's no red band
yeah it was the most unhealthy of all of
us out of who me you read ban well red
band is a he eating clean though for a
while already sure never walk he gets he
gets an uber ride to a car yeah right
red banner ago all right dude
I love you re always a pleasure bye Bob
going to spring training is gentlemen
Ari Shaffir so uh we should hey are
there gonna be any March Madness games
in our area it is gonna be yet
datacenter will be a thing we should go
yeah we should totally go yeah look it
up look it up it's usually they usually
have a round at this table center right
though whether it's earlier late yeah
see where they all are
hey dude
what do you think they betrayed I know
we talked to the patreon you know it's
what I think the Steelers Raiders got
off got away with a deal because they
won in the first run or you didn't have
to give one up I think he would offer
two for that guy it's unbelievable I
think a lot of I don't know I eat him I
think that's where we said that's where
he was gonna go we predicted that here
and I'd always heard that that's where
he was gonna go that are the Niners and
he wanted to go to the Bay Area but uh
you know now's the time with him he's
going to get
million a year for four years and he's
already 31 so he's got three years of
his prime to go and then good perfect
what's the chances of us getting to run
him back - I hear Jets are bears but
you're talking my labium Bell yeah Jets
are bears probably are the ones that are
and that's why you heard that bears were
shopping Jordan there other running back
but uh jets are bears probably is where
he's gonna go and I don't think you want
I mean anything gonna happen I don't I
don't see that happening though and
especially with Marshawn doesn't want to
go anywhere and he's such a fan favorite
there yeah but we need a Marvel
workhorse I feel like he's not that
workhorse I think is I don't know if
he's in every down back guy now I mean
Lady Anne's done in every dumb back
either
he's a you know he's not he's a three
especially now
and he hasn't played in a while I think
you guys are fighting with your
backfield I wouldn't worry about that
guy ask a question Jason of course do
you think and this is just from me
because I follow this guy's career
Antonio Gates plays another year with
the Chargers go yeah well they would
love to have him back at 38 years old I
mean just cuz he's like that guy but the
only reason they got him back last year
was because their actual replacement for
him was hurt for the year so now that
he's back I think it depends on on was
it Henry was em but what their other
Titan is on or Henry right if he's not
ready to go at the start of the season
of course he bring him back from like a
one-year deal thing for whatever amount
of money he can play yeah but yeah he's
a he's a absolutely hall-of-famer
Gates definitely think that crazy he and
play one down of college football yeah
he was a forward he was a forward and
yes it was like a Charles go forward
type player yeah yeah that's exactly how
he was Berkeley type yeah yeah he was
the the Berkeley of the Mack
mid-american conference weren't they
thinking about trying to get like the
middle ball kid one eight seven seven
cars
kakie
so this gates right here yeah see that's
there was my you met em Sam you remember
my uh my college roommate Trevor Hoffman
these all Kent State's all-time leading
scorer can you look up education of
Surrey
I'm watching my alma mater right now
flashes yeah yeah I love Brodie's
impressionist Steve Jobs is Brody
Stevens
[Music]
I don't see any appointments about Tanya
West Virginia and go to the Staples
Center positive energy I'm about to have
a heart attack or can I do one more line
of cocaine see I got a pull-out CD plan
for my city Jenna first of all eating Z
[ __ ] my baby mama
you saw that Clippers Jersey I do
thought that covered in your [ __ ] if
a man blows me does that make me queer
as eating how about the top of three or
[ __ ] hookers half price the [ __ ]
no no [ __ ] eating one Asian male porn
star calling Bobby Lee mobile [ __ ] you I
better use a magic 8-ball I [ __ ] own
you
I bought you you've it for me no Papa
champagne like up like a pop champagne
like a big come on up once what they
look like
people like iPhones you know it positive
energy I invented iTunes I've got a
battery charger I bought Pixar sold it
made money flipped it like a house we
launched Tim Allen's career what a
scumbag that guy is I'm Steve I can say
whatever I want last player [ __ ] you yes
I hold grudges don't you dare cross me
hi everybody I'm Steve Jobs and I still
use Netscape
was that improv by Brodey yeah I've
never seen that what did you guys do
that long time ago
[ __ ] Chappelle show you're the best
sketches I know it's so sad I still like
hasn't hit me Jeff said it hit him
finally last night it's like so real it
was real as [ __ ] last night his real
last name talk about some happy stuff if
it wasn't for his [ __ ] family running
the light everyone his baseball hits
like little league baseball coach when
he was 10 I mean that another
showstopper
everybody degree did his mom and sister
suck no Jeff loved that the baseball
yeah he had several great stories well
our brothers were really fired right
Jeff Ross killed they were great
Randolph kills deer and off the grave
did great I'm so proud of him you can go
watch it red bands periscope it was when
you guys are having intermission and I
didn't know that cause like I hadn't
been tuning in so was like this thing
ended at ten where's Jeff
and then like everyone's stories was
coming back and I was like I'm confused
why I can't work get this periscope to
work but then I found out you guys had
intermissions halftime Brody's family up
five comics zero he said his mom is
making great faces when the band was
playing like yeah I've been posting
random photos the band was very fun it
was great and also big shout-out to
Portugal the man thank you guys I love
those guys for them now I'll come in and
play drums oh yeah you were the bad guys
yeah it was fun you were a bass player
guitar guitar over there guitar I was
really I'm usually rhythm guitar yeah
yeah
he sets the tempo what what are you
posting I've been posting random photos
on the Instagram and I put the Billy
remember the Billy Ripken [ __ ] face card
from FLIR did you guys collect baseball
cards
we did so everyone's just going crazy
over that but I didn't realize how much
is that card run now probably a lot
probably a lot okay sorry to change the
subject
yeah thank you for stopping our awesome
conference that's a good baseball end to
talk about your [ __ ] bat I guarantee
you Brody would want to talk about the
[ __ ] bat no that'd be negative
energy negative that's the baseball card
game yep
dude listen guys go check out the
Instagram for this podcast it is huge
it's like what 3,000 people almost 4,000
Wow
it is growing by the minute it's huge so
yeah go check it out did you guys ever
collect cards oh yeah who was the it's a
basketball card it might be like John
Starks or something like that where the
the Mendez brothers are actually in the
background look you know the two
brothers that killed their parents
there's a card where there he's
inbounding the ball the min Menendez
brothers yeah and they're both sitting
right there and apparently the story
goes it was after they killed their
parents and they were running with their
credit cards and taking all their money
and they had court to both of them with
courtside seats there it is right there
that's a baseball card yeah that's a
basketball card who's that Mark Jackson
yeah is Mark Jackson yeah but that's a
tops bass basketball card I guess and
they're both sitting courtside at a
Knicks game apparently that's what the
story goes are you married now to each
other yeah they are in prison but you
know you chicks are just [ __ ] crazy
people they marry each other how many
letters there's a Steve Yzerman card and
Casey Anthony's in the background I'm
just kidding yeah yeah that was rude to
each other marry somebody in prison yeah
that's just like [ __ ] I know he's not
cheating on me it's just like can you
get your [ __ ] I just say it's just that
to have somebody put money on your
commissary card and smuggle drugs in in
their [ __ ] yeah
he proposed her during the trial yeah
Wow this guy went through a prison
divorce and I mean I think we're just
drifting I can't get a girlfriend right
now but these guys are getting married
for someone to go to prison you will be
dude [ __ ] yeah noted you should totally
do that I need to kill someone you
should totally do I'm thinking about it
I gotta get angry at somebody I don't
think that's a ball or move on your own
death sentence trial you represent
yourself and you bring up a witness and
propose a also representing yourself and
not knowing what you're doing baller
move oh yeah I remember he was like so
egotistical he's like what position did
you find her body in and how did they
get her there like he like wanted to
hear the details of his own this guy
brutally murdered women and raped them
and beat him with a log including a
child look look look look look look
that's what a murderer yes blessed are
Kelly peed on a chick and still got
girlfriends I mean like like yeah like
just like dude are we gonna act like
women aren't [ __ ] when have we ever
die can you isolate I will walk out of
here if you think I haven't made a point
to say we're gonna [ __ ] it on this
show for a decade listen we talked about
two things on a show homeless people and
how [ __ ] women are okay that's why
this podcast fake is listened by in
hands of border that's why it's the best
podcast couldn't really give me the
Cliff Notes version of our Kelly like
just dude like the bang kids and he
would buy women he had a cult or
something yeah and he was just like I
ever see frozen I'm like Jason that
beautiful I mean there's no sport I
don't see what he did that was so bad
I'm gonna be honest the Michael Jackson
thing no uh-huh are Kelly yeah I don't
see what he did that was so bad I told
you the story before that oh I liked a
bunch of women and gave him a bucket to
pee in she's up here did he
yeah is that part of what our Kelly did
yeah
oh my I heard this is a let him leave a
room and just gave them all buckets a
buddy of mine play pick-up basketball
with him and you weren't allowed to look
at him yeah but dude he gave him a
bucket you know any people wouldn't give
you a bucket [ __ ] hey I I just it's
unbelievable
oh yeah it's I mean you haven't watched
all the art Kelly one no I haven't
watched yeah I want to see the interview
though the interview sober oh the
interview is oh we kill right did you
see it no but I've seen like the
holodeck is this a camera right here is
this the camera yeah yeah yeah that's
great and everyone's like Gail you're so
brave first of all there's like nine
people in there the protector what's
gonna happen and it's if anybody's gonna
start peeing on her if anybody says
she's him hang Oprah's best friend wants
to interview you you're [ __ ]
yeah yeah no way that goes good oh yay
Oprah's cut friend wants to interview me
yeah whatever [ __ ] obviously doesn't
have anger issues yeah we are cuz you're
a scumbag you [ __ ] you know he just
pisses career Zolt going away you know
well I mean just like dude he peed on it
a girl underage right but he's still
allowed to have a career like what what
is that that brushed over cuz I was a
while ago Chris Chris Brown's still
touring punch of [ __ ] and faces well
you remember what Chuck Berry did back
in the day well Chuck Berry peed on
white chicks so I'm fine with that
okay fair enough what so let's hear you
so I gotta get on the mic Johnny tell
the [ __ ] store dammit
we can hear you the fans like your voice
people miss you I get dm's about it get
over here people like you look at the
camera like you we've got it
look at the camera like our Kelley's I
know a guy who would run events in
Virginia and when Chuck Berry was on
tour they couldn't find him for a show
every day were looking everywhere and
the police had picked him up he was
under the floorboards of the women's
bathroom looking up at women urinating
for basically two hours before show and
the police picked him up they had to pay
the police off to get him to come to the
show across the street that's the story
I mean but Hootie hurt
Hootie hurt nobody right those girls I
mean like dude ha what kind of honor is
if they have the legendary Chuck Berry
watch you paint
what about legendary art Kelly peeing on
them if that's the argue because those
are underage people they don't really
and they don't listen what direction
nobody would be crying right nobody
would cry I don't know Terry Stiles to
pee on me well you're too old right
you're more than Nickelback crowd okay
yeah you've let Nickelback crime was a
favorite band I like like classic rock
the Beatles if you have you would let
the Beatles pee on you you'd let them
old ass ring go right now come in here
and just drop a piss
have you been peed on I've talked about
this before I don't think that's weird
yeah Marvin berry modicum it's like
thank you keep eating yeah by the way
this is the greatest thing ever is
because yoko ono is such a she's a [ __ ]
dumpster and she's like playing like
Disney Hall like hey come see the chick
who broke up the Beatles and she's on
the bongos yeah Chuck Berry it's like I
will smack a [ __ ]
his cousin Marvin berry it was looking
on a [ __ ] was looking at chicks at the
enchantment under the sea dance how
mommy buddy hey anybody yeah John Lennon
smack Yoko around you ever see that
video Chuck Berry piano night chick no
Chuck Berry was doing it Chuck Berry
look at this look at
I will [ __ ] kill somebody I will kill
somebody
I will kill somebody Chuck Berry pees on
this girl in the bathtub very famous
video you could probably find it
somewhere but he's peeing on this girl
and like he's in her mouth yeah and
anywhere you pee and then he goes he
goes like they even live life he goes
like this direct quote and a good
impression you know I do semi good
impression easily the most underrated
impression this is a dead ringer of what
he said huh my piss taste and she goes
bitter white girl white girl yeah yeah
yeah in a bathtub on her knees white
women from way back then the credit they
got they deserved for being such like
visionaries my pioneers of getting peed
on did do interracial porn in the 70s
you basically weren't you were never
allowed back to your hometown uh-huh
they laid it all on the line they were
the Jackie Robinson a porn they really
were they really were and we need to
give them some a little bit of love
because now it's accepted now every
commercials black guy with a white Chuck
Berry was the OG are Kelly no but I mean
did he did you do underage girls that's
the only problem people peeing on people
it's underage girls the first word this
girl baby ever said was bitter she was
like three years old took her wallet
talk hey what uh what are the chances of
us getting a bill burr Bert Kreischer in
here than the other room are they in the
other room yeah I mean probably in a
meeting probably about zero Bert's our
friend I'm not doing that no what no I'm
not here for that Bert has called us
yeah he has called in he might call it
also home even though he's a hundred
feet away I went to get a coffee and
then pee and then I heard I was like
little spying on the meeting they're
like no we should cancel punch-drunk and
I'm like what
yeah yeah is this the longest podcast on
the network you think I think so
Aaron know what podcast has been on this
network longer than us or the olaf's has
been here the whole time
that's how Sam thinks it's the old geez
dog I am the best
no you're the best you're the
[ __ ] bass you're the best
around
[Music]
Anaheim we're deaf where they plane in
Anaheim what's down all the pyramid
probably or the pond yeah it's the pond
okay I got a feeling Dukes gonna get
eliminated early I can't believe that
they're that when they have to all the
top three well one of them's not playing
well no they have to three of the top
players go and they're not winning I'm
saying the bad the best is not playing
yeah they're a different team was iron
yeah he's gonna be I think he's gonna be
great opt reteam if Zions playing and
now they're playing like a top 10 team
without him
that's exactly why I should name for
himself if he gets that [ __ ] going yeah
probably
depending on where the sun's picked if
the sun's picked too they'll take that
kid from that we're talking about the
other day yeah so what are the chances
where they're gonna get Sion and Kevin
Durant whoa I mean do Kevin Durant would
be have to be the biggest [ __ ] idiot
in the world to go to the next right now
he just has to be an idiot an idiot did
you see that video of Dolan the Knicks
owner yeah banning a [ __ ] fan it's so
embarrassing this guy I'm gonna make a
prediction right here Lakers they might
get ad and boogie cousins that bookie
cousins just goes everywhere
I think you know dude I mean he might be
good with both those guys here we go
this is great what does this sell the
team look at all the these young Jewish
chicks oh he's just bangin look at that
so some guys yellow dogs either watch he
throws him out right there he'd get some
band right there that's the owner yes he
owner the Knicks so the guy was just
saying sell the team an opinion yeah and
now he's banned well I mean he's a
trust-fund kid Dolan I I'm he's gonna
sell I can tell you this Dolan will sell
that team within three years they're
gonna make him the NBA's gonna make him
that team has been a rack not only since
the Phil Jackson the Isiah Thomas but
what he did with Charles Oakley remember
that yeah that was weird
that was [ __ ] weird yeah he's an
idiot he won the he won the sperm
lottery he was born to a billionaire I
mean like what is he done and then he
comes back with that that PR mover he
has Latrell Sprewell sitting next to him
courtside after he he gets Charles
Oakley ban how much mighty you have to
spend on that one yeah I'm telling you
as ions going to New York I feel it I
feel it what the Cavs are gonna get RJ
Barrett nice he would be good on that
team playing next to Collin Sexton how
does it house sexing doing he's havin a
solid year right now let's see what he's
averaging do can I just tell you I love
Patrick Beverley so much he's the best
dude he is the best he how's his game
he's averaging about 18 yeah that's good
dude that's good dude that's a good he's
doing pretty well man I'm pretty
impressed but you know he's playing on a
team that nobody gives a [ __ ] about dude
were 17 and 50 what Lou Williams scored
more points than anyone ever coming off
the bench
what's that thing with him in a versa
net that clique
I don't know it's Doc Rivers like hey
our two energy guys come off the bench I
don't know why cuz he thinks they're
going up against like the second unit
it's this weird thing that yeah I mean
he's no JJ reddick they're the same size
JJ I can [ __ ] kiss dicks did the only
time I listened to basketball talk is
when I hear that beautiful name if he's
not a first-ballot hall-of-famer
I'll suck my own dick what are the what
would you give me to get JJ Redick on
the show I would have I don't think you
and I could even I don't think I could I
couldn't version all Sam when it
couldn't would not be allowed to be here
none of us could be here so just be you
yeah for different reasons that three of
us couldn't be here because he has a
podcast yeah it's not bad it's not bad
but is it a video pod because I just
want to look at him because he had a
Chris Paul and they were talking about
the Clippers when guys this just in
breaking news Oh breaking it sound
effect Jets make final offer to Le'Veon
Bell and give him a timeline of tomorrow
to sign it and then Ravens make a
counteroffer so Ravens are now in the
mix for Le'Veon so it looks like jets or
Ravens
Le'Veon could be one of those two before
the next punch drill for money look up
Kylie Jenner before she had always liked
Griffin with Blake Griffin it was ugly
when he was in college and weird looking
he was weird look it's wonderful person
now he's gorgeous he's sexiness was
before it fixes teeth true or false
is he hot Blake Griffin hot or not
red-headed black guy in his sherbert
dick orange sherbert dick
he's like cute but not hot Oh God the
Sinbad of Basra don't touch him
[ __ ] no you come on you want a
billion billion dollar baby
I love my kind but dude look how good
he's yeah you have a type look how great
he's playing in uh and he looked
terrible in college dude rude yeah he
look like a but he's a kid they're
copies this is the Blake Griffin the
Clippers wanted that they couldn't get
it because of Neal Brennan sketch show
I blame Apatow Neal Brennan II we're
coming for you Apatow if that guy buys a
house we should just egg it hey guys I
just like that we're so powerful we can
get shows cancelled cancelled and get
Brody's uh back in funny people yeah
look at us do we are a powerful crew hey
where'd you get that uh t-shirt at a gas
station that's [ __ ] up yeah I think so
you remember when I came on the show and
I go and nobody's gonna believe me but
the Clippers gonna be good this year I
said that I tweeted it you say it every
year no but dude come on everybody
thought they were gonna tank this year
because they didn't want any loser there
pick nobody thought this team was gonna
be this good and I knew they were dude I
knew that I was watching them in the
preseason I'm like this team can score
dude look at this dude we're supposed to
take this year we're six games out boys
it's seven games out you're ten up seven
out seven out from what do we have ten
games left about less than twenty dude I
can't wait till we [ __ ] destroy the
Lakers this week what a [ __ ] fest I love
the Lakers and pelicans almost had this
exact same record I love it and they're
both they're wood they were the most
talked about teams in the NBA for some
reason yeah yeah yeah I mean the Lakers
always are 15 games out okay those are
about three three weeks about three
weeks in Portland's home we could beat
them
Chicago's winnable Portland's Brooklyn's
winnable and that's a team I don't
understand Sam [ __ ] they had every
reason to tank and we're taking and
doing that
no they're winning games they shouldn't
win I mean they were at the fourth worst
spot and then ninth in the East then
they start winning games like what are
you doing yeah
well that's what the Cavs are doing now
Kevin Love came back and now they're
playing inspired basketball for what
though for who for what you know II mean
well the aisle I think it's almost
impossible for Cleveland to get another
number one that's quickly the NBA won't
allow it
yeah for sure because I mean we got
LeBron we got Kyrie got trician we got
dion Waiters we got you things ion goes
to the Knicks we do say that I did too
and I think that's a great fit and that
will really spark I mean they haven't
had something like that since your boy
Owen when they got him it just spun the
city it's the best team in New York
right now they're fun to watch they are
fun to watch and I like Brooke I like it
being Brooklyn to do way more than
jerseys
throws at Jersey Nets I didn't like it
as much as I liked to Brooklyn it yeah
the Barclays center yeah yeah I mean he
was gonna sell the team but I don't know
if he's gonna do it now
jay-z no jay-z's not part of that
anymore because he had the divest for
his rockefeller he's rockefeller agency
how funny is that Bell like he had that
going and then LeBron just came and
stole his milkshake start his own one
now everybody sign with LeBron
I forgot jay-z it was an agent for a
second yeah alright it's just crazy I
mean so we'll see dude I think this
might be the end of the Warriors as we
know it it was a nice run I mean
everything has to come to an end except
for the Patriots apparently but yeah
they keep going strong but yeah
everything I mean it's unbelievable they
just keep going strong it's just uh the
[ __ ] AFC is just dog [ __ ] no we can
because if I McGregor so I'm having him
yeah oh you did I didn't hear about this
oh he grabbed the fans foam who died
[ __ ] are you oh there's a video of him
hold on Pall Mall nah she's doing beer
bare-knuckle fight yeah yeah yeah mm
once McGregor to come do it I'll bet you
do I can't stand these guys he's a
[ __ ] too by the way I like Paul I
don't commentary but dude stop
challenging MMA guys to boxing matches
no it's just McGregor they just want to
paycheck
is this one is this what this when it
happens this is when you get the recipe
okay so he just grabs somebody's phone
and threw it or somebody wanted they
were taking pictures well did not that's
what Blake Griffin did to him what do
you do grab their phone and just through
it yeah and then you went to jail for
that so the guys probably pressing
charges you yeah of course he is he's
trying to get paid man that's so gross
so gross
I like McGregor I know you know I mean I
like he's a good bad guy I find him
quite funny I root against him in the
Octagon I root again you know depending
on who he's fighting I generally have
rooted against but him the whole scope
of it I find quite entertaining he
brought a lot of excitement to that for
another match I was into it I was like
oh I want to watch this he has to focus
on fighting yes I saw that one that one
I've seen that one I've seen yes the
focus on fighting he really does he's a
good [ __ ] talker and self-promoter yeah
of course I'll give him that but I don't
find it entertaining she sounds like
yeah I mean we need to in the Octagon I
root against him flexi : but he makes me
laugh when he welcomed the punch showing
sports
Ryne Dalton finish your thought put the
speakerphone on yeah Tom you should be
working why isn't working is it
hello Ryan how are you dude I'm good
what are you doing
you're on punch strong sports right now
oh my god if I I think I dude longtime
listener first-time you know the dude
you're up for collar of the year
oh my god so words we're talking women
women's tennis yeah yeah we are we are
by the by the cackle in the background I
assume yeah if he's annoying you just
tell me I'll put him in the penalty box
[Laughter]
so what's the word did you know just
getting done running
we were talking football big football
signings this morning with the regular
crew from the Comedy Store that lives
around the corner from me Guam felix
we're talking all sorts of crazy
signings today and Cleveland Browns
futures that's what we're talking about
well I mean what do you think dude it's
looking good right I mean you guys gotta
be happy Baker Mayfield worked out I
mean dude everyone saw it like what are
you doing you got a good running back
after 14 game suspension we don't know
yet we got a general manager reminiscent
of Kevin Costner in that dress see
here's the thing dude John Dorsey we did
it's I mean like I'm sorry but that
isn't like Ray Lewis I'm sorry that's
not ray little you're 100% right I mean
just like all things are equal it's just
ridiculous right now
it's just ridiculously but you should
never call black people the n-word
either right am i right
we learned something too that you know
it's just I'm just this outraged culture
is just that is not that listen man he
didn't he didn't hit her
did he knock her over yeah that's what
happens when everybody's drunken being
stupid when you tell me that I hit a
woman and I didn't I kicked her get your
story straight
eating kick her didn't like Bruce Lee
karate kick her well he picked at her
when she was on the obviously Dalton's
masturbating right now yeah either I'm
walking down the sidewalk look either
way John Dorsey saw Dannette can at the
outlet store and bought it for a bargain
no no no you're totally right you're
totally right it's gonna turn around I
mean I saw the tape it's a shove it's
not like Sid he's sitting there and like
Hitler and I practiced on an elevator
all right
the reason the NFL the reason NFL's
gonna drop the hammer on him is became
the why they're mad is because he lied
about it yeah
he lied to them about it and then the
tape came out and it made the NFL look
bad and that's gonna get him eight games
had he been totally outright and honest
about it and the probably maybe would
have got a game or two well you know he
all says an argument it's like he's
already been suspended they cut him I
couldn't work yeah bidet today they
definitely on countdown they don't come
back you know he'll get like six eight
games probably which is great for the
browser that's what the Brotherhood
exactly hello Ryan Dalton that's what
the he'll call back but that's what the
Browns are hoping for they won six to
eight games might have been attacked by
Panther a Florida panther oh no I've
known Ryan since the seventh grade
I know how crazy is that that's crazy
it isn't find it kind of hard I would
love to known chad sumac in the seventh
grade have a lot of by Chad's built up
oh by the way shout out the UH Steve
somebody with an s okay he who came to
the house of comedy and I'm Santa you
know meeting everybody up to show and he
just goes by Chad forgot about Brody
moved on in our lives you know we have
to get back to that people are talking
about the by Chad Pacquiao
people are like it's revolutionary
following this lady on Bell thing yeah
alive as we're doing it
Antonia Brown may have leaked it
but said congratulations to Le'Veon for
getting that money he tweeted that even
though no deal is official so now it's
really kind of looking like he may be
going to the Jets what's this new get
that money culture that everyone's get
that money go get that paper go get that
money paid why not it just seems I don't
know Instagram models can do it why
can't pro athlete I don't know just like
I don't know I like to think she's guys
are playing for nothing doesn't mean
everybody else has to so yeah I love the
game you do that's what I'll say about
Chad he loves the game yeah I don't even
know what game we're talking about but
you do love that but it just seems like
I don't want to root for these guys when
they're just get that money
I don't root for you this dude but at
the end of the day we're fans we're
paying their money
yeah but the bottom line is this yeah
and you have a maybe six to eight to
twelve year window to work you got to
make a lifetime's worth of money in
eight years and you're gonna be
physically impaired for the rest of your
life so I say get that money get that
money dude yeah Chad why don't you go
get that money I want to root for these
guys again like when I was a kid I
really felt these guys really cared
about the cities they really care about
the organization's they play for but now
that I'm old I'm jaded it's like you
said it's just a different thing it's
not even like what used to be gone are
the days where you just like like how
Walter Payton was like drafted by the
Bears retire a bear you're the city of
Chicago your entire career and you know
buy a couple car dealerships in the town
and when you're retired and blah blah
blah
Reggie Jackson now you're now you
everybody's gonna play for four or five
teams or Reggie Miller but Reggie Miller
another good example of that
Patrick Ewing another good example of
that yeah Jordan I mean for the most
part like Mark Grace who was one of my
favorite childhood players loved Mark
Grace like hand at first base white yeah
any more number 17 and I grew up
watching WGN so and I got his rookie
card so I followed his whole career but
he went
Arizona to win a World Series but he
didn't want to go he loves Chicago did
you see his rookie card where he's
holding that bat and it says cumdumpster
if you blow it up I'm gonna really yeah
it's a very famous card what's your
what's your number-one rookie card you
have ooh I have a Java Deion Sanders
baseball and football rookie oh wow and
with the Yankees and him with the powers
I don't know I mean like 30 bucks I have
that too is that that one with the three
you know sent away for the upper deck no
I have and I have a kangaroo feed Junior
nineteen eighty nine dollars more but
per deck he just got injured all at the
end yeah you know I have a 1980 Rickey
Henderson tops ah that's a good one
yeah Brooke that's a good one it's gonna
be worth tens of dollars I have a Vic
Rickey card
Oh Michael Vick you have this one is it
really 5,000 bucks he was a
hall-of-famer before he started doing
steroids I heard his card is corked
thank you everybody
I like that one that was a great one
Barry Bonds Jeff what else what else
notorious [ __ ] by the way is that
true oh yeah my brother everybody that's
ever met him and said he's a [ __ ]
[ __ ] in person my brother used to be
in charge of the concierge and Ballet's
about this hotel in Phoenix where all
the protein stayed okay and Judy said by
far the biggest dick of all the pro
athletes always heard that was was
what's his face and then he said the
worst team he said hockey players were
the nicest oh you always hear that
baseball and then he said but the worst
was the New York Knicks
they were just pieces of [ __ ] really
what about NFL play in an NFL team you
know well in that he didn't say anything
about I never heard anything bad about
that we met Baker Mayfield he was cool I
met him and then I showed you that he
was there you you walked through there
made Baker Mayfield I thought people
don't know that he was the first person
to ever introduce him to you yeah it was
like such a little detail that no one
really needed to know
I met him no no he has his ownership
qualities I made eye contact with him
first
and then I allowed you to be next to me
to talk your shad walks right by him I'm
like are you Baker Mayfield I'm like
chance Baker Mayfield I didn't believe
it yeah you're like no I'm like it is
doodie he's walking around with an NFL
gear on stop acting like you don't want
to be seen homeboy he had a shirt on the
tent I'm Baker Mayfield ask me how yeah
I dude for sure okay by the way kudos on
the good coffee today at ATC they
promises coffee
they got us coffee Starbucks you got it
we made a complaint and guess what boom
verdolino
here's coffee shout out the agency got
it did you do caveman yeah look I
brought my caveman we did not but guess
what guys and I was hanging out with my
good good friend I love them so much
take Fletcher last night go to our good
friends
caveman coffee user code punch drunk
caveman coffee calm and that gets you I
believe 10 or 15% off whatever you buy
and they got everything there's night
rows are great and Sam's got a bunch of
nitrous for me I gotta remember remind
you of that bro there in much wrong so
go to caveman coffee dot-com use the
code punched on my trunk that's not this
trunk though sorry my other trunk bro to
my other truck it's here
yeah and so go to came in coffee that's
the best the best the best the best the
best man coffee so you were lurking the
whole thing last night that's what your
soon yeah I was trying to do the
periscope so I actually didn't see the
periscope I just was watching people's
live Instagram what did you see that you
liked it what made you laugh anything
anyone speaking I was just like seeing
pictures oh okay Oh bad job lurking yeah
you usually well I was going to be
responsible and go to bed early since
Jeff was out and then I was reading a
book called golden state like I'll be
gone in the night about the golden state
killer and he was such a freak that he
would just like watch women in their
sleep for like nights before he would
attack it was like with no pants on with
a boner with a ski mask that's what
that's my move so then that's all I
could picture and I was like [ __ ] now I
can't sleep because I just pictured a
man with a ski mask so I was just up
reading this book - dude that's a joke
Halloween costume
ski mask and a boner no pants killer
calm down do you think it a boner
because he was so turned on by what he
was about to jewelry comes in with a
boner pill if it was me I'm coming in
already hard but I'm coming in hot
always but yeah that's a good what was
you saying chicken of the egg with his
boner that intrigued me a little bit
like how does he have a boner for like
hours just standing the only way I could
get bar that's performance-enhancing
drugs the only way I could get heart is
if I think I'm gonna kill a girl
now I'm getting hard like this after he
would rape the women he would like make
them go to the kitchen with him you need
all their cheez-its and like Ritz
crackers rocks right talk slower and no
one make eye contact isn't that's such a
Power Move
they said like he would just eat so
slowly like the husband's all bound and
gagged nothing to watch this I was very
intrigued by this book wait so he would
tie up the husband and make him watch
like as he rapes the way rapes the wife
he makes the kids watch too it was the
easiest thing ever that's totally fine I
don't know why everybody's making this
weird
you like the crackers but I knew you
would so then and then right then it
kills the wife - no rape I'm not to
where he kills but it is about the
Golden State killer someone assume he
kills right now I'm just that like so he
ties up the husband rapes a wife makes
him watch and then while he's tied up
and she's got what's coming to her then
he eats all their crackers yeah one guy
said he ate all our cantaloupe too so
there is that so he eats that his last
moves closing move is like and now I'm
gonna eat all your healthy now I'm gonna
eat all your snacks he also would do
this crazy thing where you would tie
them up and then just watch them for
hours and then they would think he was
gone because they haven't heard any
movement so they would starts like try
and get out of their tongue and then he
would pounce on the bed and just breathe
on him to be like I'm still here but say
nothing and then go away again and do it
again and then I was like getting chills
and was like god that's so creepy
then he would tie up their kids make
their kids watch and then like they
would call for their kids named after a
couple hours be like honey you still had
like mommy no and then they'd like rape
in front of the kids
is this where entertainments going
because I'm just uh
pedophiles killers mass murderers this
is entertainment now for all of us we
need to go yeah don't do anything
offensive but let's read about rape and
murder of women that's why I like the OJ
trial so we're gonna have to chant you
guys getting me too worked up here
I think the OJ trial was the the the
premiere trial for serial killers
athletes and reality TV well if you
really think back on it and you watch
that the documentary on on Bundy that
thing was like a Super Bowl like the
entire that's right and that really was
the first super trial to Ted Bundy thing
when you saw how many people were
watching that and it was like four
channels back then there's nothing else
to really watch that thing was the
original OJ trial yeah you know well the
difference with him is nobody really
knew Ted Bundy like OJ was like an
iconic figure that's true he was like 79
years old he got away oh yeah I know
that [ __ ] I don't know I'm just add all
the rapes right now yes that's right
yeah yeah yeah she's reading the book
that's when you were getting coffee just
tell us about this book yeah yeah he's
creepy as [ __ ] you voicemail messages
yes lightning months later yeah yeah
yeah yeah I remember kids like game
statements it said like they'd see him
what there's no pants and his boner and
they'd be like who are you is like I'm
here to play with your mom you daddy
like so scarring just ties them up and
like make some water where I'm at right
now at least you know what true crimes
big right now so we're getting numbers
we're getting hit we are hashtag this
and that's just that's hashtag rape rape
who's the new golden snake killer Steph
Curry
durant for any minds because he's gonna
kill that team when he leaves
Durant's the canoe Gold mistake killer
because when he bounces by fish Lisa
that guy on the right who gave that
description at the bottom right okay I
think he had a balloon for a head and
the one other laughing like he looks
just like Elvis Presley one four year
old kid was like mommy what did the
doctor do to you cuz she woke up like
unconscious like all like tied up and
he's like what the doctor do to you why
was he here do you remember your well no
not yet where I'm at but he my can't I
think of his name that he lived with
with a see hang maybe he was peeing off
the roof who are Anthony no no no I knew
his I always get mad you do all those
videos but he was get mad cuz he would
say like he wasn't getting away had
Medellin
oh yeah for sure conspiracies
conspiracies for sure dude for sure
hey uh so oh yeah let's not forget to
announce April thirteenth punch-drunk
sports UFC look it up the UFC the next
ones the big one that we're doing we're
doing it Chad zoo mock chasing t-ball ah
the black guy Kareem Kareem are you
drinking milk and and and a newly
announced guess who else will be there
bill burr and Joe Rogan why do so buy
your tickets now oh yeah ever been on
the show you're like they might be here
fight [ __ ] will also be there you go you
go and me I go yeah you'll be there
this just said Marc Maron's on the show
Oh awesome awesome awesome awesome and
also Brody Stephens will be there yes
how about all the MMA fighters that come
to your shows let's get them to our
viewing parties yeah I love you they
love you can we get around it around the
court all things comedy bill a hologram
bro deceive isn't like a humorous
hologram Michael JB a matter of time
it's gonna be in the matter of time so
who's the data card
Holloway - man Holloway scares me I love
him he's great but he just looks like it
Gastelum in Israel out of Sonya who
might be my favorite fighter right now
I mean well he's the he's Anderson Silva
2.0 yeah he meant OSP versus a Nikolai
Volkoff that looks interesting that's a
good card man that's a great card dude
that's a great card is the main fight
Holloway is that the yeah that's the top
one okay cooker do gas illuminatus on
yours well it's like have you seen them
staying next to each other it's I can't
believe they're in the same weight
division that's a real what are the odds
on that that you could bet on on bet DSi
user code one guy six for the other ones
five nine
how tall are you Chad five nine yeah I
need a fight UFC is what you're trying
to say
for sure ah gas limit is probably the
favorite in that right yes I mean I
don't know if he's the favorite but if
gasolin is the favorite I would throw
money on Sonya on that DSi okay but it's
close huh I mean that dude is smaller
longer stronger faster how much he gets
taken down that's gonna be the big thing
if Gasland could take him down he's got
shot he's got shot outside you know yeah
I like the card this is kind of dumb but
I think Sports is all about the entrance
and the music like what would your
entrance song be if you were happy
birthday to you I feel like that gets
you pumped it gets you jack right
I mean well what song do you walk on to
onstage uh like the power bi Public
Enemy yeah gets me jacked up mmm
what about you ah it's this it's this
random song by this band I like to I
like to leave the show - Steve Lee's
bands you're the best
it's great outro song well Sam's in an
event yeah thank you it's not just a
stand-up comic it's an event oh you're
talking about walking up to do comedy
yeah oh I thought you're saying if
you're like a fighter what would be your
thing not really yeah it still it would
it mine would be the same happy birthday
to you both
mine would be like Britney Spears my
prerogative and then Spice Girls spice
up your life you're so ridiculous dude
young Britney Spears was the hottest
girl in the world yeah remember when
what's-his-face from Limp Bizkit got
[ __ ] for banging her yeah I started
banging her and everyone's like [ __ ]
so I'm like dude we'd all crush that
right now yeah yeah he was such a tool
that he couldn't overcome that by the
way Michael Jackson owns happy birthday
to you holy [ __ ] look at that on the
left come on oh oh date her do you think
she's got a ton ik I would take her out
for a soda pop and then I saw her
[ __ ] head off obviously how come she
hasn't posed nude yet god dammit I feel
like we're they only three guys in
Hollywood they haven't seen her fun bags
and purse I remember she stepped over me
what yeah yeah I feel like I did know
this and I thought you were so cool then
and I think you're even cooler what
music video was it toxic Dana did this
he did it for Dana so she had no
underwear on I mean she had somebody
could still see where babies came from
right just shove your whole [ __ ] fist
up in my gosh of the camera dude
somebody wants to call in right now and
I think you're gonna enjoy them okay I
just plug it in alright keep it ready
this is a better B Britney Spears based
off a sketch I wrote called a fakie
Jason T when I wrote it
you basically wrote this song how about
our game show called up your ass that's
hilarious
very underrated sketch we should tweet
that it's really funny oh here comes
here comes Sam she steps right over me
while she was hot
shut up dude he wrote this song I wrote
this [ __ ] song
you should be loaded they basically
created you Johnny oh that you Sam look
at you don't they say that's like very
clearly Sam that's so cool you put that
on your IMDB yes it's the number one
thing on my Wikipedia that being called
the n-word by Paul Mooney oh I did too
everybody's done that yeah it's a
blessing that's hilarious
he made that documentary a lot of people
don't know that yeah so what were you
just talking about that's actually the
best that's funny dude like I'd rather
have that as a credit than and that's
the name of this episode paparazzo perv
like it like i have like a legitimate
credit on the ghost whisperer I'd rather
have that I'll drop the [ __ ] out of it
all right
well I'm tired what else would someone
supposed to be calling it yeah who
called him dude you're by the way you
are like if this hasn't happened you're
over two on guess he just texted me is
he still coming in as he saw on his way
what's his name I'll call on
he says I'll call out on 201 number so
pick up a bear be Chuck D dude anything
less than that you're know this one's
kind of fun Tebow will like it it's
better be Chuck D Cup the porn star
how's it not a porn star named Chuck D
cup I don't give a [ __ ] equal right you
can have a baby named max but I can't be
a porn star named Chuck D cup that's
pretty funny so far it's been fun I'm
having a good time I'm crushing I mean
definitely you were you are absolutely
killing it have you lifting we're up
late though weren't we oh here we go you
ready do we go hello okay go ahead Sam
ladies and gentlemen punch truck from
New York City Kevin Brennan Neal Brennan
City he's my number one New York City
[ __ ] I love him the most listen I just
want to sorry for your loss Sam with the
on the Brody stuff but I was trying to
watch the de Brody I watched some last
night and I was trying to watch part 2
today yeah and then the score brothers
came on and I just I couldn't do it I
mean it was so it was so bad with their
[ __ ] double toss I was like I wanted
to [ __ ] kill myself
yeah have to Nick you subs [ __ ] our
speech I wish I'd died yeah I mean I
mean it's like it's like how are those
guys successful it just goes to show
anyone can make it if you're Jewish
twins I think that's the key that's the
key I mean you take to one unfunny guy
and then you multiply it times two and
you're like what could go wrong
[Laughter]
we can't let this get back to him though
yeah we can yeah we can't he's the best
guests we've ever had they can do fight
us murder those guys no way those guys
can fight it just so everybody knows I'm
not kidding you're listening out there
you guys can tweet me and tag me I stand
by what I said uh-huh keV now Kevin's
you hear a crashing I canceled your on
the one of the last episodes I did see
you on that yeah Chad no you know I
tweeted it was funny because I tweeted
because the night I let Sunday night
there was the last episode so I got into
a fight with my wife not because of that
just earlier in the day she's talking
about it it's basically like sitting by
myself at a coffee place just like
tweeting and being a dick you know huh
so crashing the crashing Twitter tweeted
out something about Pete Holmes was
getting giving like comedy tales so I
think we do it I said I said I said it's
I said giving out county tips when you
just got canceled now that's funny right
so [ __ ] Judd Apatow who doesn't even
follow me on Twitter you can look this
up you don't even follow me on Twitter
he retweets me and he says well was
after your first appearance any
coincidence
and I'm like [ __ ] so he's coming
after me which I which I don't mind but
it's just like you know follow me or
don't follow me don't [ __ ] shadow
follow me yeah
don't troll me and not give me a fall
yeah so it's like it's like and I don't
think I'm like how does he even find out
that I tweeted it wasn't his tweet it
wasn't even Pete Holmes tweet it was a
[ __ ] crashing HBO tweet and somehow
he finds it and then he [ __ ]
basically calls Matt because he doesn't
even comment like a side tweet he
retweets it so he can basically punch
down on me but like I love the attention
I'm not gonna lie
um plus I was in character Sam because
on the show I played a [ __ ] bitter
[ __ ] and that's what I that's I'm
staying in character might we'd love
that do you find yourself do you find
yourself as an actor getting typecast as
a bitter [ __ ] how many I need the
money I'll do anything I'll suck a black
dick do you know what I'm saying
I do know what you're saying you're
saying that you'd suck a black dick
that's what you're saying
yeah I would only if money's involved
though yeah I would love that yeah I
just want to know like what was your
process I'm acting I know you probably
went to an acting coach and really
really got got into character was that
like well you know what it was you know
it's funny
the guy that I did the scene with fat
will Silvan I really genuinely don't
like the guy gotta be kidding me Sam Sam
I'm not even kidding he's a horrible MC
he he mumbles he's the worst MC like a
lot of times I don't even doggy ins
doesn't even know he brought somebody up
but I I know how he he's Haitian I kind
of know what he's saying and I and I'll
pick up like him mumbling my name so
I'll just go up you know but he's
horrible he never says anything good so
it was kind of like a blessing that I
got to do the scene with him because it
was I didn't have to do any moment
before I didn't have to consult with an
acting coach they're like you're gonna
do a scene with will and you're gonna be
annoyed I'll go yet no problem yeah I
don't even need a script at this point
just let me go yeah you're already
off-book yeah yeah I'm mostly a date
they had me like ad-libbing for like a
long it seemed like a long time but I
don't know how long it was but so most
of stuff that I said I don't even think
it was it he was in the script but I
don't want I don't watch myself because
that's how I am me and I Brad Pitt we
don't watch herself no I couldn't watch
because it's so I saw it so I like I
don't like the way I don't know it's
just watching my wife was watching so I
was kind of watching you're watching her
like she had like air pods on so I
couldn't hear what I was saying so I
could just watch my face my face was
like not great so I'm like I don't want
to hear what I'm saying
every now every now and then like which
she was watching you're seen with her
with her earphones on but she just
turned to you and just shake her head
like no [ __ ]
well she's are disgusted by me anyway
but but uh I I said well like it was a
good she goes it was alright hahaha cuz
everybody else was like no it was good I
was like well I don't know how good it
was but she but she was basically very
like Sylvie I don't want to give me a
big you know like it was all right you
know right
what do you explain myself so she's sick
of that anyway
anyway um yeah I fell Chad did you know
I fell we've gone to the subway you fell
no I I heard something about that well
what exactly happened he broke your hand
yeah I was running for the subway I felt
like down five flights of stairs oh I
thought you see we're saying you fell in
love with somebody on the way to the
[ __ ] no no I don't make me laugh cuz
it hurts my [ __ ] chest is all [ __ ]
up I might have a broken collarbone it's
like it's all [ __ ] up I just yesterday
we did you just did this like yesterday
um no it's like 10 days ago but I'm
still having like side effects that [ __ ]
now I'm getting like a burning sensation
in my [ __ ] right chest
have you been to the doctor twice she's
a [ __ ] quack I mean you got all their
Union money now with that that role of
my Jungian body yeah go see a doctor to
do like 20 more scenes on crashing to
get my Union to get my [ __ ] elephant
swords why do why do you say she's a
quack what did she tell you no cuz I
it's just like I don't trust her like
it's like I'm like what's the why's it
hurt why is it hurt I fell like two
weeks ago Thursday or like 12 days ago
and now all of a sudden I'm getting
links I'm getting like a burning
sensation in my chest and she's like no
it's just I go yeah I don't know
probably I don't know but it just it
just came out of nowhere so it's really
annoying anyway I want to tie you guys
up so anyway r.i.p Brody Stephens a
great man and he's a great I it says
that happened I was sitting in a hotel
and uh in [ __ ] a Mohican Sun and
polkas on
reverse plugs but uh and I'm sitting out
I'm like I'm like this is gonna
devastate the LA scene because I knew
everybody loved him and I knew he was I
know he was like the epicenter of the
[ __ ] Comedy Store sure well and I
just knew it was gonna break everybody's
heart that he did this so yeah it's been
well that was like a moment with from
Kevin Brennan well you know when you
start acting you tend to get more
emotional that's something that
something will make me laugh Sam don't
make me laugh
something got rattled loosen him when he
fell down five flights of stairs Kevin
are you still doing dates with louis c.k
are you guys done
no he I was doing some on that now he's
canceling some I just got another cancel
I'm getting more cancellations but I am
booking he's canceled canceling because
of protests or what's he canceling for
no no he cancelled because I I don't
know I haven't seen him but I just heard
we had I did want to Florida and I think
he's like I think he's just pacing
himself is what it is I don't want to be
quoted because uh yeah I guess but I
think uh I think the comedy community
for the most part has stepped up to
defend him and I hope he keeps going
dude I think he has a right to do it and
I mean they're conflate they're just
[ __ ] blowing this thing that he did
way out of proportion I mean ya know he
was but we did a week in Tampa at side
splitters and there was like there was
not one we did like when's Wednesday
through Saturday there was not one
protester the fans came a standing
ovation before well when he was
introduced when he got done so I think
he says I think he was he was gonna do
more dates but I think he's like I think
he got a little tired just like
physically tired cuz he he kind of went
from like not working that much to
working a lot I think it got physically
tired yeah and I think he just wants to
like pace himself a little bit I'm that
just what I'm guessing I'm not I've been
spoken to a but uh cuz he knows he can
sell tickets you know I think he was
worried that he would not be able to
sell tickets or what was the bad guys
going to be but now I think he's he's
pretty confident like I mean it's
obviously knows he could sell tickets
and so that's kind of that worry he's
kind of been put put to rest and now now
I think it's just a matter of him pacing
himself on how much he wants to go out
there you know
is he taking people's phones we need
when he does it yeah but the Comedy
Cellar is doing that now too late every
show they take people's phones oh for
every show yeah so I just start out I
walked the other day I was like
everybody had their [ __ ] phone
packets and I'm like so they're doing at
the Comedy Store might have to start
doing that too now so I don't know
what's going on hey we were at Brody's
thing yesterday and I noticed Neal
wasn't there do you have any inside info
on that Oh Chad Chad who's Chad who
asked that Chad yeah Chad Chad sorry
Chad was here nine days he already
burned a bridge at The Comedy Store yeah
no you don't I think it is you know I
think it is like Brody was like really
had mental issues and Neil has pretend
mental issues if you watch three mice
you eat it's all pretend mental issues
so Neil knows he's a fraud and he didn't
want to be called called out and Brody's
saying like hey look at the fake phony
mental guy look at a guy who's got a
Netflix special out of being mentally a
fake challenge where a guy really
[ __ ] hung himself who should have got
a [ __ ] Netflix special because he
obviously did so Neil doesn't start
cutting himself with something he bring
Billy he's a [ __ ] fraud because
people with mental problems kill
themselves brothers and sisters you have
I'm one of ten and Neil's the youngest a
tenant too bad my day that my dad didn't
pull out after nine I said it's now
house hey Sam how sweet was my mom's
[ __ ] that my dad never pulled out after
having nine kids your mom had had you
guys really sweet sweet [ __ ] I'm not
gonna lie that sounds like a real sweet
puss yeah what do all your other
brothers and sisters think of you and
think of Neil what's that
what do that was the whole family think
of your Neil's little feud that's going
on I mean we got other feuds going on
one of my sisters done talked to two of
my other sisters she don't talk there's
all kinds across here so I
now they people are aware of this but
they don't they don't really give it
that much you know they don't expect it
was your mom's [ __ ] womb Fight Club
what the [ __ ] is going on yeah that is
that is a lot of people to get along
especially too many kids look at the
look at a [ __ ] Michael Jackson family
all that talent and all that [ __ ]
Fame and it's still they're still all
crazy when will one one of the one the
Brennan's come out as a serial killer
huh when will one the Breton's come out
as a serial killer oh I would love it
cuz then maybe I'll get off on a Netflix
show always working always working cash
always angling always ingly Brennan
maybe you know cuz that's [ __ ] I'm
watching that [ __ ] guy a Ted Bundy
I'm like well they gave him a [ __ ]
special where that's [ __ ] special
several if you have to kill a
[ __ ] back east of you know what
I'm talking about Sam I got an idea
where I know I'm talking about I smell
your breath keV I know what you're
talking about um when you gonna be out
here again I don't know I know I'm not
like your loved here sir you are loved
call me Chad didn't give me any names
but he said Chad told me when I when I
was out there last time people are going
up to like I guess a couple people ask
Burt why'd you even let him do your
podcast
that's hilarious like that's [ __ ] as
far as our buzzer that's [ __ ] gold
yeah we're the land of misfit toys so
you're always welcome buddy
you're always well alright buddy alright
thanks take my call take care bro
Congrats Congrats on crashing I love him
absolutely love him we had Ari and him
and crime true crime talk this is the
bus yeah [ __ ] sports yeah it's what
we're always saying to you less NBA talk
more fun [ __ ] sports and can we sit can
we just say it free our Kelly free our
Kelly's free my heart Kelly I just found
out about this little thing here what oh
great don't like this be on this side
area
alright guys that's a good show right I
feel good about that Johnny what would
you give our score on the show [ __ ] you
man
Auto rot of a 1 to 6 o of 6 good I like
that
alright Erin thank you thank everybody
Sam thanks for double parking
god bless Brody Stevens god bless Brody
seasons